do everything cereals too real I like it
cereal mm-hmm I think cereal is pretty
surreal I don't get it
apples or oranges what fruit is better
for throwing bananas for throwing them
it's like a boomerang yeah yeah
have you ever gotten a boomerang again
back to your person no I have it but to
be fair haven't spent that much time
with booboo right away however here's my
thing if you take a banana and then
slowly start to unpeel it and then throw
it not only in my cartoon imagination
does the banana unravel out of the peel
so you have two weapons at once first
they're distracted by the Verdana coming
out their face then there's a peel on
the ground so as they try to run they
slip on the peel Hepatitis good stripper
name sure if fat ankles are called
cankles are fat risk called Chris mmm
really good question mm-hmm um no what
are they called fists Fabrice how's
Maggie and she's great cheesy tell us
about your worst Shing story but only
use either three words or three phrases
um mm-hmm
carpool oh no late Oh too late
golden co wants to know how do you feel
about elbows mmm pretty good yeah yeah I
mean I feel like you know the funny bone
I'm not cool with but the elbow itself
why does it do that I don't know like
what's the fun it's like oh yeah yeah
yeah like I'm sensitive watch this weird
thing I do when you hit me in a weird
way and who's the person that called
that like instead of like watch out for
you Tribune anoon who is like that's
your funny bone cuz it makes it feels
funny it's like a lot of funny feeling
no it's a bad feeling I don't know yeah
I call it bad bone delao CFC wants to
know do you think cows are sassy cows
cows definitely look at those I like the
eyelashes like mama and then they're
like mom I think you've only seen
cartoon cows I think have you ever seen
a cow's eyelashes in real life no
they're beautiful
don't cows have a yes cows actually
remind me of you they have brown eyes
and eyelashes and then sometimes they do
that nose big
Eric ventures wants to know what's your
biggest short person problem I don't see
any I don't have any problems with it
you're short-sighted I'd nailed it and
Tyler Oakley has asked can I have my
wardrobe back Oh sassy and today on a
day that you actually do have the same
shirt as him yeah
sorry Tyler I'm sorry they give good
taste and but I'm older and was born
first so maybe it was my wardrobe first
Wow
oh did he mean though that large armoire
I borrowed when you're trying to get to
Narnia them oh oh my goodness Tyler you
can have both your wardrobe and your
Ottoman back sorry about that okay open
your eyes welcome to your toilet well in
so many ways this challenge is based off
of the salt and ice challenge on YouTube
which if you don't know is incredibly
stupid and essentially as you put salt
and ice on your hand until you burn it
and have a scar this salt water well
some of them are salt water and some of
them are vodka ice what's happening here
is that salt water and vodka ice look
very very similar when they're in shot
glasses so you and I when we playing
never have I ever
if you don't know how to play that game
you basically say a statement or a fact
if something I have never blank blank
blank and if you have done it you have
to take a drink so the first person to
do four shots of saltwater noses I'll
start I'm just starting off very lightly
never have I ever had sex with a woman
don't regret it when was it hard to tell
I don't know it was oddly carbonated oh
that was probably the vodka I'm
definitely thinking about saltwater
actually oh yeah yeah you got one I
never ever ever never ever kissed a girl
you have to drink if you've done it I
don't know I thought it was that you
were trying to make the other person
right but also if you have done it you
have to drink also yes I do over all
right I'll give you one Mulligan okay
never have I ever fallen down stairs and
busted open my head but is it that's not
why yeah that's how it is
ha ha ha Wow it's always traffic in your
mouth oh I forgot about this Cheers
cheers to making bad choice then yeah ok
it's one to one
oh never have I ever shaved the side of
my head
oh yes Oh
vodka this yeah bouquet Wow okay never
have I ever failed at doing a back
handspring on stage in front of a live
audience
it was a back walkover and I never have
I ever
ha ha horn I carrot onesie have you
never put on the car was not sober I
don't know fine boy I wish I cared
everyone ok yes am i doing one yeah what
is it it's so much worse after you've
just been bought guys because it's so
not that at all it's so not sweet so
what is it it's two to one yeah never
ever ever failed at doing a back
walkover
I never have I ever written my date a
three-page email after a bad first date
with them you've said this on camera
before I cannot talk to you right now uh
you shouldn't talk to me good damn it
yeah yeah never have I ever peed on my
friend's hat yeah well it was in one of
a kayak where sparked I wore it the next
day
never have I ever had my hat peed on by
a friend I peed on your head ha ha ha
America yes dammit
America I'm just gonna lie alone um
never have I ever pooped in someone's
front lawn you're really missing out
good or bad I catch all good never have
I ever
cartoonishly projectile vomited into
this rapey
sniffing if someone had the fake vomit
thing next to your mouth it was a windy
road and I got caught it was a windy
winder road how it was winding oh yeah
oh yes
never have I ever touched a cow brain it
was for entertainment move on over no no
very nice taken Halloween yay yeah yeah
yeah there it is that's the last for
okay okay never have I ever
never have ever met the president that's
right I'll take this for you America
yeah you were Obamacare
Oh is the Affordable Care Act never have
I ever passed up the opportunity to meet
the president there were circumstances
around it we were shooting this podcast
that day trust alright Oh God never have
I ever
ha had termites that's not a plate on
you that's a plate on your housing
situation and also that's a plate on you
could be I'm gonna be say goodbye dear
say goodbye to your deck oh what a putt
so many termites on that dog a good
smell like Denton again why me why we're
gonna solidarity but really yeah oh
that's my office
oh yeah yeah how's this charlie the
sound back anyway if you want to live
into the full podcast with Hannah Hart
go over to iTunes and subscribe to not
too deep with grace mobic and revved up
that make you do if you puke this will
be a viral video I know I really almost
forgot I can't tell if that kernel at
the bottom of the bag is like saved or
didn't get to fulfill its potential
so is that kernel happy it's not going
to get eaten and destroyed or sad that
it never got to be the only thing it
ever wanted to be to do